i could light a fuse at any time and
turn into another full-on brawl and i'm
sure johnny johnny will win this time
[Laughter]
just kidding
many of us used to be enemies
but rivalries
don't need to last forever cobra kai is
back and this season we have johnny and
daniel on the same team after playing
adversaries for more than 35 years what
was it like to finally be on the same
side oh my gosh it was um
it's so much fun because william and i
know each other for
forever and have this shorthand
that uh
between our characters and as actors and
we play off of that these two characters
are equally as entertaining when they're
getting along until when they aren't and
when they're getting along we yearn for
them to to butt heads and when they're
budding heads we just want them to get
along you know they're gonna
eventually figure it out but it's so
much fun to watch them fail
there's only one way we're gonna be able
to beat them kicking their ass is so
hard
themselves william what was your
favorite bonding scene between johnny
and daniel this season
the training scenes the the mutual
training scenes i love i mean i got a
kick at i mean do it is whack you know
sand sanding the floors and painting the
it just felt so strange doing it because
obviously i watched the movie and i did
it now johnny's doing that and then but
but i think really one of my favorite
things is seeing
is seeing larue so at eagle fang just
just
just climbing things walking on coals
and you know taking balls in the head
and you know and then and then the
hockey fight that was really fun i think
the exchange of uh you know the
philosophies of styles it's great and
it's great for the characters because
they're now in with different
perspectives and different tools moving
forward so i would say that that was my
that was my favorite stuff come on we're
gonna get sued here uh sue me for what
tighten that cord and we did get to see
another showdown between johnny and
between daniel i was not expecting to
see that in episode five and then you
guys knock each other out the same time
and it ends in a tie what was your
reaction when you found out that after
all these years they face off again
and it's a tie
they keep that up pretty pretty well the
the writers are so uh conscientious and
conscious of
you know how to how to give a uh not the
whole meal but this was pretty much a
meal it's a mid-season kind of moment i
thought it was really carefully done
william and i worked really hard and
they had a little more time than usual
and it pushes all the right buttons in
and the reasoning and the and the attack
of each other but it's
it's kind of friendly in a way and ends
it ends in that that uh
there's still no answer but um and then
there's this big resolve on and then
it's the breakup again you know we we
want to do this for the kids but we just
don't belong together you know it's like
a married couple it needs to put the
kids before themselves and i think
that's that i credit the writers and and
their perspective and all of us and and
figuring out a way to have that showdown
and it be all and everything but yet uh
shed new light in other areas
is there another showdown in our future
between these guys william
oh well
all can't be well
you will see i mean the great thing the
characters are they started as such a
they're so far apart and there's so many
landmines that are planted in between
you know especially on johnny's side
because johnny had a skewed sensei in a
skewed life daniel has a little more
balance you know so yeah i think uh you
know we'll see uh we'll see but i love i
love where where the characters come
back full circle in the tournament and
acknowledge you know especially johnny
acknowledging you know his errors and
coming together and they're better
together but they just you know like you
know people have uh
they have differences and those get in
the way so that could light a fuse at
any time and turn into another full-on
brawl and i'm sure that johnny johnny
will win this time
[Laughter]
just kidding
they're not the only ones teaming up
this season we see the incredible thomas
ian griffith return as the intense terry
silver he did not disappoint ralph what
was it like having him back and going
face to face with someone who tormented
your character right that's a great
question listen thomas is as often has
been the case in in cobra kai through
these seasons every anyone who comes
back from the original film series
brings their a game and then some it's
really been
a spectacular journey that i never
expect if you ask me you know five ten
years ago you're gonna be doing a tv
show and thomas ian griffin is gonna
come back and play terry silver and you
you know i do there's no way i would
ever say that would have ever happened i
mean it's interesting i say some of the
maybe shortcomings of karate kid three
are now the fruits that we get to bear
in season four and it's really a
spectacular and uh
and thrilling journey and even to play
that stuff so it's almost like you get
to redeem any missteps from yesterday uh
going forward you just don't want to
admit there's always been a little cobra
kai in you well my last question for you
you guys are just wrapping season five
what can you tease for the fans we end
season four we have chosen back in the
valley this is so exciting
what little morsels can you give us
william uh i mean the the resolve of
johnny and daniel at the end of four is
good i mean they're you know they're on
good terms so we don't have that in the
air right now but we do have a miguel
off somewhere
and um we have some you know a a
rekindled relationship with johnny and
his son robbie which i love so much so
uh hopefully we'll see that expand a
little bit
but where is where is diaz and what's
going on and then uh you know we have a
new king in the valley it's uh it's a
little bit uh what are we gonna do with
that
um and i'll put that on the russo
shoulders yeah okay so um
i think the uh you know
there is i mean those points are all
well spoken i think also
you know chosen the big uh the big uh
cliffhanger moment um it's what you know
you make a deal
johnny and daniel make a deal with chris
whoever wins it's you know the others
shut down like what happens from there
how can we let it go and what um um
outside of you know mentioning like
miguel and rob it's so nice to see the
robbie johnny that moment it's so
beautiful in season four with billy and
tanner and uh
and so what happens even from that
perspective with robbie and daniel who
had a very close relationship in a hard
falling house so maybe there are places
to build on that and how chosen falls
into the world and what
that element of miyagi-ism is brought
into the forthcoming story so there's a
you know a lot of conflict and a lot of
left turns when you think you're going
right and that's what we are proud of
have the man boys filled you in on the
whole mortal enemy karate dojo battling
for the soul the valley thing
[Music]
you